هؤلاء ليسوا الطرف الذي يريد ان يقيم يقيم
السلام بل هم الطرف الذي له يد في اشعال
الحرب وكل الجرائم التي ارتكب ارتكبها
الكيان الصهيوني جاءت ب يد من الولايات
المتحد اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم هيئه التجاره البحريه
البريطانيه تقول ان حريقا اندلع في سفينه
استهدفت بمسيره على بعد 200 ميل من سواحل
الهند ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان
الطائره المسيره اطلقت من ايران والحرس
الثوري الايراني يقول ان على داعم اسرائيل
توقع اغلاق البحر المتوسط ومضيق جبل طارق
وباقي الممرات المائيه مع استمرار الجرائم
بحق الفلسطينيين وتجدون المزيد من اخبار
حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول
القوات الاوكرانيه تعلن انها اسقطت ثلاث
طائرات مقاتله روسيه من طراز سوء 34 في
جنوب البلاد وتقارير اعلاميه تذكر ان
مدينه اوديس ساحليه جنوبيه اوكرانيا تعرضت
لهجوم بعده طائرات مسيره روسيه وقامت
القوات الاوكرانيه باسقاط ايضا في هجوم
منفصل مجلس الامن الدولي يعرب عن قلقه
اجزاء انتشار العنف في السودان بعد يوم من
من اعلانه ان الحرب هناك تسببت بنزوح 7ب
ملايين شخص مددا في بيان مشترك بالهجمات
ضد المدنيين وتمدد العنف الى مناطق تستضيف
اعدادا كبيره من النازحين وطالبي
اللجوء وزير الطاقه والموارد الطبيعيه
التركي الب ارسلان بيرقدار يقول ان بلاده
تخطط للاكتفاء ذاتيا في مجال الطاقه خلال
العقود الثلاثه المقبله معلنا تجاوز انتاج
النفط في جبل جبار شرقي البلاد 30 الف
برميل يوميا الى
اللقاء